foreign
[Music]
Baywatch movie but you decided again I
haven't turned it down completely yet
but I have
turned down what they offered me but
we'll see what happens they work for
such a huge part of my life and it was
it's really they're trying to do an
homage and you know it's an honor to
kind of have them let me be a part of it
so bad
in spot number four that time she played
a game involving the stars of the new
Baywatch have you ever played Mary
kissed or killed no okay I'm gonna give
you three names you have to tell me who
you would marry who you would kiss and
who you would kill I'd kill them all
you wait till you hear the names okay so
it's three of your Baywatch co-stars so
Zac Efron Dwayne The Rock Johnson and
David Hasselhoff Mary kiss kill marrying
Dwayne kiss
Efron and uh freaking killed
oh it's not enough fun on this Earth You
Know Zach is wealthy I'll marry him
taking over spot number three Pam and
her parents in Vancouver for Earth Day I
think I learned how to work really hard
for my mom and my dad and they taught me
to respect the environment being vegan
is better than driving a hybrid car
you're saving the environment and you're
saving yourself
in spot number two Pam stepping into a
new role as creative director for a
social platform we're really looking for
a connection right now don't you think
I'm such a romantic and always looking
for ways to help people either you know
fall in love or or make their
relationships more interesting and stay
together and I don't know it doesn't
really work hard for me but I'm still
searching so
and last but not least we love to hear
her talk about her love of Canada as
soon as the plane lens and I always seem
to see the Rocky mountains and snow and
and the fresh air it's just you know
wherever you're from is where you feel
most comfortable I'm Canadian I'm an
island girl any chance to be home I want
to be home